Ali Vaez
is the director of the Iran Project
at the International Crisis Group,
and he's joining me now from Washington.
Welcome back to the program.
Thank you.
Great to be with you, Christiane.
So, okay, so look,
remind us where we were this time
five years ago
in terms of controlling
the Iranian nuclear program
and where we are now.
So on eighth of May
20, 18, Iran was under the most rigorous
monitoring regime
that has ever been established by the UN
nuclear watchdog.
It would take Iran about 12 months
to enrich enough
nuclear material
for a single nuclear weapon.
And Iran was fully complying
by its obligations under the deal.
And of course, by the time that President
Biden walked into the Oval Office,
that timeline had shrunk
and is now right now,
according to Pentagon officials,
at 12 days
instead of 12 months, it is 12 days.
And Iran has rolled back
a lot of those monitoring mechanisms.
And so the transparency of the program
is way
less than what it was in the past
than the IAEA is blind
about a lot of Iran's nuclear activities.
So in one sentence, Christian,
the Trump administration
managed to take Iran's nuclear program
out of a box
and to put it in the microwave.
Wow.
That's dramatic, the way you say that.
So just just just be clear.
The Trump administration said
that we can get a better deal
and they launched
a process called maximum pressure
where they tried to squeeze
Iran with more sanctions and a lot more
punitive measures,
thinking that
that would cause them
to act in a different way.
What exactly did maximum pressure achieve
Well, it has been an abject
failure across the board.
Of course,
it has brought Iran
to the verge of nuclear weapons.
Iran has never been closer
and it has also rendered
Iran much more aggressive
in the region in 2019.
You remember the hot summer of that year
when Iran started attacking
shipping lanes and tankers and energy
infrastructure,
including in Saudi Arabia.
And it has rendered Iran
much more aggressive
and repressive at home.
We have seen that every protest
that has happened since maximum pressure
has been met with the brutality
that we've all seen on on TV screens
in the past few years.
And I will want to also add
that let's not
forget the fact that the Iranian people
have been living under
not just pressure
from the above,
from their own regime,
but also pressure from the outside,
from the United States and estimates
suggest that at least around
600 people have died as a result of short
shortages of medicine
that the US sanctions have caused
Oliver.
So what then is the option?
We said,
and we know that there have been
basically indirect negotiations
between Iran
and the United States
via the Europeans
and the other signatories to the
what was known
as the JCPOA, the nuclear deal.
But President Biden was caught
sort of off Mike not so long ago
saying that this deal is dead.
Is it completely dead?
Is there any attempt?
I know that you and other experts
like Vali Nasr
and even J Street, the
the the Israeli activists,
the Jewish activist group in Washington,
have called
for a different kind of engagement.
Can you walk us through that?
Sure.
First, Christian,
let me say that as a proponent
of the nuclear deal
with Iran, it's
very hard for me to admit that
the Biden administration
and the hardliners
in Iran succeeded
in what
President Trump failed at,
which was to kill the JCPOA.
Now, there's plenty of blame
to go around.
I think obviously the original sin
was committed by Donald Trump But
but then the Biden administration
hesitated in 20, 21 and in 2022,
Iran miscalculated and lost
multiple opportunities
to restore the deal.
Right now, as we speak,
I think the White House's preferences
for some kind of a narrower agreement,
an interim deal
that would just freeze the program
so that it would not become a problem
in an election year
as we enter into the campaign period and
and the Iranians
are really not interested in
anything less than the JCPOA
because even the deal itself really
didn't benefit them economically
as much as the extent expected
a narrower deal would definitely
not do that.
So we're currently in a situation
that I describe as no deal, no crises
that I think
the Biden administration
would want to extend until 20, 25.
But there are two problems with it.
Number one, it is unstable.
We're really at the mercy
of a single incident.
If Israel, for instance, commits
another sabotage
of an Iranian nuclear facility,
assassination
of an Iranian nuclear scientist,
we might see
significant escalation
in ways that would cross a US or Israeli
red line, for instance,
if the Iranians enrich to 90%.
The second problem with with the strategy
is that imagine we can keep a lid on it
until 20, 25.
Then what
in 2025
Iran would have 200% of the leverage
it had in 2015.
It is not going to agree to a deal
that is tilted
more in the interest of the United States
is probably going to ask
for way more concessions
that even the next administration
would not be able to afford.
And that is why I think time has come
for a new thinking,
different kind of thinking.
And what we are suggesting right now
is that if you look at
the current situation compared to 20, 15
and 2015, Iran had good relations
with the West and was on speaking terms
with the United States but bad relations.
What its neighbors in the Gulf region
now is the other way around.
And in that there is an opportunity
to make sure
that Iran can actually benefit
from an agreement
by encouraging the economic incentives
to go to Iran via
the Gulf
rather than from Europe
and the United States.
And in return
Iran and the Gulf Cooperation
Council countries
could come to an agreement
that they would all
accept permanent limits
on the level of enrichment
and reprocessing
of plutonium
and on ratification
of the additional protocol,
which ensures
a very high level of transparency
in a permanent fashion.
So let me
then put this to you,
because I've obviously interviewed
quite a few people on this,
because it is getting,
as you say,
to a very, very threshold level
and very rapid breakout level.
I spoke to former Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton
not so long ago, but of course,
it was also at a time
which is still the case
where many people around
the world are very, very concerned
that what happened
in violating the human
rights of so many people in Iran
during the women's protests
the jailings,
the executions,
the sham trials, the crackdowns.
None of this is conducive.
This is what Hillary Clinton told me
about the possibility of negotiating.
I would not be negotiating
with Iran on anything
right now,
including the nuclear agreement.
I think that, frankly, horse
is out of the barn
when Trump pulled us out.
We lost
the eyes that we had
on what they were doing inside Iran.
And I believe that
they started those centrifuges
spinning again.
And I think it's unlikely
that any agreement would be agreed to.
And I don't think we should look like
we're seeking an agreement
at a time
when the people of Iran are standing up
to their oppressors.
So, I mean, that's a compelling case
for not dealing with them at this moment.
Do you think that still stands
is that kind of feeling and I understand
it exists in parts of the EU as well.
Is that going to sort of
rule the day at the moment?
Look, the West can choose
not to negotiate with Iran,
but it wouldn't resolve the problem.
Iran's nuclear program is still advancing
at the speed of light.
And at some stage
we would be once again
faced with the dilemma of
whether we can live with Iran
with a bomb or bomb Iran.
And so
we would eventually get to that stage
unless we find a solution
And, you know,
it's true
that it's difficult
to deal with unsavory murderous regimes.
But if we wanted to apply that logic,
for instance,
to the Soviet Union
and say that as long as the Soviet Union
was engaged
in violations of human
rights or policy or foreign policy,
that was problematic
from the Western perspective,
we would never agree to arms control
deals with them.
We would be living in
a much more dangerous world right now.
And a regime like the Iranian regime
that cannot be trusted,
even with pellet guns, as we have seen
it has blinded
hundreds of peaceful protesters
in the past few months.
How can we distrust this regime
with the deadliest weapons out there?
And so I do believe that
regardless of the nature of the regime,
there is a need to find a solution to
this nuclear crisis.